bethe declares for the presidency
Elizabeth Warren text to the center and
President Trump runs up against his own
party I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show I have many many thoughts
on paedo many thoughts on beta we'll get
to all of those thoughts in just a
moment but first let's talk about how
you can make your business better hiring
used to be hard multiple job sites
stacks of resumes a confusing review
process but today
hiren can be easy you only have to go to
one place to get it done that's zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire zip
recruiter sends your job to over 100 of
the web's leading job boards but they
don't stop there with their powerful
matching technologies zip recruiter
scans thousands of resumes to find
people with the right experience and
then invites them to apply to your job
as applications come in zip recruiter
analyzes each one and spotlights the top
candidates so you never miss a great
match zip recruiter is so effective that
80% of employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the very first
day and right now my listeners can try
zip recruiter for free at this exclusive
web address zip recruiter dot-com slash
daily wire that's zip recruiter Daum /
Dai ly WI re zip recruiter comm / @
daily choir zip record is indeed the
smartest way to hire there's no reason
for you to agonize over having to send
out 1 million of post requests and then
filter through a million resumes instead
check out zip recruiter comm / @ de Lee
Weyer zip recruiter the smartest way to
hire zip recruit comm / @ daily way to
go check it out and try it out for free
when you post unzip recruiter using /
daily wear alrighty so the big moment
has finally arrived bado is off the
fence that calls for some music guys
that's right Beto's in Oh
kickflip bomb rip bado is in so exciting
I know everybody is very excited the
Millennials are so raucous that they
just smoked a larger joint than usual
the progressives are so into it that
they looked at bado and then went now
we're gonna go with Bernie the moderates
looked at beta and they're like he's
like young Joe Biden Wow how impressive
beta O'Rourke okay let's let's start
with Beto's announcement so yesterday he
is featured on the cover of Vanity Fair
magazine this tells you everything you
need to know about beta O'Rourke if your
announcement is essentially made on the
cover of Vanity Fair magazine we know
what you are you're a white elite
liberal okay this is what you are and
the reason that the media love
themselves some beta the real reason the
media love beta is because they look at
beta and they see themselves they look
at beta and what they see is a a white
kid who grew up extraordinarily
privileged in a rich situation who spent
a few years kicking around before he
found himself and settled down
who has broadly liberal views the
left-leaning views but likes to think
through the issues is really considered
and temperate but also cool right the
cool guy whose kids think he's cool also
a little bit nerdy but really mostly
just cool and like a guy you'd want to
hang out with and be with basically when
the folks at CNN look in a mirror they
see beta O'Rourke and that is why they
love beta O'Rourke the same thing is
true over at MSNBC when chris hayes
looks at mirror he sees beta O'Rourke
and that's why all of the media are in
love with with bado when they looked at
Barack Obama was even better because
Barack Obama mirrored all of those
things except for the race so they could
say they were intersectional and also
Barack Obama mirrored who they think
they are the considered politician who
really likes to think through the issues
and then comes up with sophisticated
analyses who spent a few years kicking
around until he found himself helping
the downtrodden
that's how folks in the in the
journalistic world like to see
themselves all the people who went to
NYU journalism school all those people
see themselves as beta O'Rourke which is
why every fawning profile of beta
O'Rourke is written by the same former
NYU English grad who is sitting in a
crappy apartment in Brooklyn overlooking
an
and what you bumming is pissing into a
trash can hey everyone every one of
these profiles is written with this
sopping I'm writing the Great American
Novel attitude so the Vanity Fair piece
in which bado essentially declares his
presidential run is no different the
cover of the magazine if you can't see
it is bado standing in the only shirt he
apparently owns every picture I've ever
seen of beta O'Rourke he was wearing
this blue kind of beat-up shirt because
he's a man of the people despite the
fact that he's worth nine million
dollars and his wife is the daughter of
a near billionaire and his father was an
extraordinarily powerful County Judge he
there he is man of the people standing
in jeans cross a lonely road in Texas
just standing there considering his
future maybe he'll take out a guitar or
flick his bangs out of his eyes and play
you a ballad yeah okay so Vanity Fair
has this program the profile is SEMA is
just as pathetically drooling over beta
over work because all of these profiles
of beta over orc are the same sure he
has no ideas sure he doesn't know at the
hell he's talking about
sure he's never done anything of real
importance but beta O'Rourke is a man
who likes to think through issues and
consider them and he'll take your point
of view into into consideration the beta
O'Rourke is the guy that apparently a
lot of suburban women are into and he
was the guy in high school who a lot of
the girls were into why because he was
the guy who seemed deep but it turns out
that he was just he seemed deep because
he was a mirror meaning he look like
there was depth to him but he was just
mirroring back to you what you wanted to
hear and that is basically what beta
O'Rourke has been for his entire
political career and the media will love
this they love it so this Vanity Fair
article in which he was photographed by
any Leibovitz the article is written by
Joe Hagin who is just the same as every
other columnist who has ever written
about beta O'Rourke there's a great
thread someone put together on Twitter
of all of the physical descriptions that
the media have given to beta oh look
he's sweating because of his passion
like he's playing great rock in a hot
Stadium and then there's talk about how
he's just relaxed leaning back looking
wistfully at the world every description
of beta O'Rourke is exactly the same
because everybody who's writing it is
exactly the same so this entire Vanity
Fair piece it has got pictures of bado
sitting with his dog
his dog looking for Lauren Lee at the
camera like why am I here what am I
doing here that's the best part of every
one of these pictures is the dog just in
the background looking like I can't
believe this is my life now anyway hey
here's what Vanity Fair writes about
betta O'Rourke betta O'Rourke's mission
style home in the El Paso neighborhood
of sunset Heights is the site of a
famous 1915 meeting between Mexican
revolutionary Pancho Villa and US
General Hugh Scott while renovating it
O'Rourke had a wrought iron fence around
the property removed saved for a few
feet of it around a pistachio tree in
late February he came home to find
Republican protesters live streaming
video and asking why he still had a
fence mimicking trump's remark that
politicians like walls when they're
around their own homes
I said come up with me and I'll take you
to our front door he recalls this is
just decorative fencing why do you have
walls in your house they retorted why do
you have a door okay that's true behind
the door in the old roark living room
and here is where we get into the deep
heart of the media's love for bata
behind the door in the O'Rourke living
room a floor-to-ceiling bookshelf
contains a section for rock memoirs Bob
Dylan's chronicles a favorite okay and a
step god the pretentiousness of people
who sit around reading Bob Dylan's
chronicles
cannot be overstated a stack of LPS The
Clash Nina Simone but also a sizable
collection of presidential biographies
including Robert Caro's work on lyndon b
johnson i love that this means that he's
a sophisticate again all of the members
of the media who love bata o'rourke
consider bata o'rourke one of them
that's why they love him hey look I also
have Bob Dylan's confessions crawl
chronicles on my shelf also when I was
in high school I liked to clash and I
also like to skateboard a little bit or
at least I wish that I had most of the
kids in the media are actually the fat
kid who was sitting with the typewriter
in the a/v room but but they wish they
were beta made it was the kid they
always wish they'd been arranged in
historical order the biography suggests
there's been some reflection on the
gravity of the presidency but there's
also some political poetry to it a sense
that our work might be destined for this
shelf he has an aura oh don't describe
to me his aura first of all the the
rigorous party of science describing
politicians with an aura good stuff
right there from from
it is worth noting here that the same
members of the media who have spent
years at this point
praising bethe O'Rourke and overlooking
the fact that he lives in a three-story
house in El Paso and is worth nine
million dollars almost none of which
came from him presumably or at least was
made really only from family connections
the beta O'Rourke is somehow a man of
the people but Howard Schultz the head
of Starbucks there's a big article in
The New York Times today about how
Howard Schultz isn't as poor as he said
he was when he was growing up Howard
Schultz has said that he grew up in the
projects there's a big article in The
New York Times today well you know the
project he grew up in was actually kind
of middle-class so obviously he's a liar
okay now do Alexander Ocasio Cortez guys
now debate oh not gonna happen
O'Rourke and his wife Amy an educator
9-year his junior both described the
moment they first witnessed the power of
O'Rourke's gift it was in Houston the
third stop on O'Rourke's two years
Senate campaign against Ted Cruz every
seat was taken every wall every space in
the room was filled with probably a
thousand people you could feel the floor
moving almost it was not totally clear
that bata was was what everyone was
looking for but just like that people
were so ready for something so that was
totally shocking I mean like took my
breath away shocking and then bado says
I honestly don't know how much of it was
me it's a rockumentary it's a rocked I
mean this this is political spinal tap
guys it is a rock documentary in which
beta O'Rourke plays a fake political
candidate on TV I honestly don't know of
it how much was may but there was
something abnormal super normal or I
don't know what the hell to call it that
we both experienced when we're out on
the campaign trail he says I don't ever
prepare a speech I don't write out what
I'm gonna say I remember driving to that
I was like what do I say
maybe I'll just introduce myself we'll
take questions I got in there and I
don't know if it's a speech or not but
it felt amazing because every word was
pulled out of me like by some greater
force which was the people there the
people are the force I am the people the
people are me give me another rip on
that bong bro that's quality quality
weed it's he's so obnoxious this hour
he's so obnoxious and again the media
fawning over this guy as though he's a
self-made
as though he's a person who came out of
nowhere
here is beta oh rocks life story okay
we're gonna do beta you know what hold
on one more quote from a tow truck and
we will get to beta or orcs life story
which the media love because this is the
media's life story
most of them grew up middle class to
upper class in big cities growing up
with a lot of privilege and then they
found themselves and now they see
themselves as purveyors of the truth who
are broadly liberal minded and then look
at beta and they're like yeah that guy's
me beta O'Rourke was a useless person
for most of his life and then he became
non useless later on in his life and we
are supposed to think of that as a
spiritual journey or in other other con
any other context we would think of that
as a person wasting opportunity really
so he final quote from a tow-rope before
we get to his short biography this is
there's something that happens to me he
says or that I get to be a part of in
those rooms that is not like normal life
I don't know if that has ever happened
to me before I don't know if that would
happen again
Wow what what an amazing amazing guy and
we're gonna get to his political
announcement in just one second which is
filled with this sort of platitude in
his garbage first let's talk about
making your home safe so you know you
have a wall you have a door maybe you
have a fence because you're not a dummy
and you want to keep your house safe one
of the things you should have around
your house is a ring okay the brings
mission is to make neighborhoods safer
you might already know about their smart
video doorbells and cameras that protect
millions of people everywhere ring helps
you stay connected to your home anywhere
in the world so if there's a package
delivery or a surprise visitor they'll
get an alert and be able to see hear and
speak to them all from your phone that's
thanks to HD video and two-way audio
features on ring devices I love ring we
have ring at our house it allows me to
know who is showing up and ringing the
doorbell at any time and regardless of
where I am in the country I mean I can
be in New York and if somebody rings the
doorbell I can say that I'm in the house
which prevents my house maybe from being
burglarized that's how a lot of
burglaries happen to basically people
ring the doorbell and then if nobody
answers they go and burglarize the house
as a listener you have a special offer
on a ring starter kit available right
now with a video doorbell and a
motion-activated floodlight cam the
starter kit has everything you need to
start building a ring of security around
your home just go to ring.com slash Ben
that is ring.com
slash Ben go check them out right now
and build that ring of security around
your home ring comm / Ben okay so then
fair uh sure Zin bado and again that
tells you everything you need to know
the entire circulation base of Vanity
Fair is upper-class white women that is
everyone who subscribes to Vanity Fair
and that's who bado is going for so
here's Beto's announcement first of all
we should note
Beto's a liar like one year ago baito
said that he would not run for president
so let's just play him saying he's not
gonna run for president and then we'll
play him saying he'll run for president
I'm not looking at 2020 and in fact him
completely ruling that out not going to
do that no matter what win or lose
you're not gonna run I'm not I'm not
running in in 2020 I gotta tell you it's
it's incredibly flattering that anyone
would ask me the question or that that's
that's even up for discussion but but
since people have asked the answer's no
yep fast forward to today mate O'Rourke
his announcement Amy and I are happy to
share with you that I'm running to serve
you as the next president of the United
States of America this is a defining
moment of truth for this country and for
every single one of us the challenges
that we face right now the
interconnected crises in our economy our
democracy and our climate have never
been greater and they will either
consume us or they will afford us the
greatest opportunity to unleash the
genius of the United States of America
we can begin by fixing our democracy and
ensuring that our government works for
everyone
this is going to be a positive campaign
that seeks to bring out the very best
from every single one of us that seeks
to unite a very divided country there's
a lot more to come but I want to leave
you with this the only way for us to
live up to the promise of America is to
give it our all and to give it for all
of us what do you mean what does it mean
for us to give us her all and give us
all of us in all of our all and all of
us and here are some spiritual camp band
leader hands whoa check this out hey
okay so we're gonna get to Beto's a bio
now because here is the thing about this
the media have proclaimed for years that
what is the real problem in America is
the problem
rich white privilege that is the problem
in America so it is good to know that
finally for the first time in a long
time a rich white man growing up in a
rich powerful white family and marrying
a very rich white woman and spending
years playing in a punk rock band
uselessly can also be President of the
United States that's good America has
grown guys you got that a rich white guy
who married a rich white lady and has
run for office and failed in an attempt
for Senate finally a person like that
could be President of the United States
slow clap America well done it's gonna
be fun to watch all the intersectional
Democrats in the media suddenly embrace
beta O'Rourke who's presumably the least
intersectional candidate of all time a
man who calls himself bado
but who is whiter than I am by a
longshot so let's go through who is bado
Mickey Rourke who is beta Oh drunk so
beta O'Rourke is a fellow who was born
in El Paso Texas to an extraordinarily
powerful family so his father was in
fact a powerful local Democratic
politician his father was an impact Oh
Roarke he he was nicknamed bado in
infancy because he grew up in El Paso
his mother was the stepdaughter of the
secreto Secretary of the Navy under
President John F Kennedy and his dad
served as County Commissioner and County
judge had a work was also a close
associate of the Texas governor so
obviously bata grew up in very difficult
circumstances a little beta was growing
up really on the rough streets of El
Paso
he began his education at the escuela
Montessori del Valle preschool and
continued to Rivera elementary school
and Messina elementary school and then
he went to the Woodberry forest school
in all-male boarding school in Madison
County Virginia just like all the
underprivileged little kids between
graduating high school and starting
college he was a summer congressional
intern in the Capitol Hill office of US
Congress person Ron Coleman then he went
to Columbia University where in junior
year he captained Columbia's heavyweight
rowing crew I mean is this an
intersectional inspiring story or is it
an intersectional Spirent inspiring
story he graduated with a BA with a BA
in English literature which means that
he was qualified to be a professional
useless person which fortunately is a
job he's fulfill
old well he's also been arrested a
couple of times but he's been arrested
for cool kids stuff right cool kids
stuff so long as you happen to be well
connected so he was arrested back in
1995 for breaking into the University of
Texas El Paso campus he's arrested for
burglary his misdemeanor was then waived
and of course as everybody knows he was
also arrested in 1998 for a misdemeanor
DWI after he was driving so drunk that
he actually crossed the median line and
crashed into somebody apparently head-on
and then fled the scene of the arrest so
beta O'Rourke you know really making the
most of his youthful opportunities his
dad by the way had his own political
issues as well
his father apparently apparently was in
1983 sheriff's deputies installed a
radio in installing a radio in the Jeep
of Pat O'Rourke his dad found a condom
filled with a white powder believed to
be either cocaine or heroin according to
press reports at the time a sheriff's
captain then ordered the substance
destroyed and was indicted by a grand
jury on charges of official misconduct
and tampering with evidence
so that's bana O'Rourke's dad right
that's family in which he grew up the
kind of family where if sheriff's
deputies find a full condom filled with
cocaine in your truck they destroy it
for you clearly bado was on a path to
self-made success our Oaks public life
started in 2005 according to the Houston
Chronicle when at the age of 32 he ran
for City Council and became one of our
Passos youngest ever representatives
that was the same year he married
Amy Hoover Sanders Amy O'Rourke was an
educator and Charter School executive
she is a constant presence at his Senate
campaign events in 2006 the person who
became very public for the O'Rourke
family just a year into O'Rourke's
Council tenure he became in meshed in a
controversial urban renewal plan
led by the Paso del Norte group a
non-profit business organization
spearheaded by his father in los you
have to understand that between the time
the pay towtruck graduated from Columbia
University and the time that he decided
that he was going to be a local
politician he played four years in a
punk rock band so his great claim to
fame is that he didn't need money enough
that he could actually afford to blow
several years running around the country
playing in a crappy punk rock band he
also worked as a live-in caretaker in an
art mover
he's basically Justin Trudeau Justin
Trudeau the Canadian Prime Minister grew
up extraordinarily privileged
extraordinary wealthy and then it was
best known for being like an elementary
school PE teacher and then became Prime
Minister because he was handsome Bernie
Sanders that's basically Beto's shtick
so a rock worked worked as a nanny and
an art mover before working for an
Internet service provider and that's
when he started talking about how he
didn't know what he wanted to do with
his life and I just would brood I just
sit there and I'd brood remember several
weeks back there was an entire New York
Times article about Beto's brooding how
he was brooding now just like he brooded
then because we love people who brood
there's so dark and meaningful as
opposed to people who actually have
purpose in their lives who just go out
and do they don't had the privilege of
being able to sit around and brood which
in other circumstances we would call
intellectual and moral laziness in any
case baito returns to El Paso in 1998
and then he co-founded something called
Stanton Street technology group his wife
Amy operates the business now he also
published an online newspaper called
Stanton Street which he modeled on the
Village Voice and then he decided that
he was going to run for City Council and
that's where things started to get dicey
for young bado when it came to his
public career in 2006 he became in
Michigan a controversial urban renewal
plan led by Paso del Norte group a non
profit business organization spearheaded
by his father-in-law as originally the
envisioned the plan called for
redeveloping a blighted part of downtown
El Paso including a largely Hispanic
residential area called Segundo barrio
opponents feared gentrification and
dubbed it urban removal so this was
young bado
getting involved in non
intersectionality he was going to
redevelop parts of El Paso but there is
a bigger problem for young bado
residents and business owners facing
displacement organized and filed a pair
of ethics complaints with the city
setting Oryx ties with his father-in-law
William Sanders was a real estate
executive in Texas they complained that
O'Rourke was quote impermissibly
entangled in the Paso del Norte group's
downtown revitalization plan through
both family and business ties his
critics is according to Houston
Chronicle honed in on past work
O'Rourke's tech company had done for
Paso del Norte as well as his vote to
approve the group's downtown 2015
development plan a work had been a
dues-paying member of Paso del Norte
though he dropped out soon after being
elected to the council eventually the
ethics Review Commission dismissed the
complaints and they said it because even
if it was true it wouldn't be a
technical violation of ethics ordinances
but opponents argued that O'Rourke's
daddy-in-law stood to make millions
through a real estate investment trust
called the border Plex Community Trust
which was formed to buy real estate in
downtown El Paso for redevelopment and
they would have aggressively used the
city's eminent domain powers which is
hilarious because now beta O'Rourke
stands around talking about how
President Trump is gonna have to
aggressively use eminent domain powers
to build a wall that's very bad it
wasn't quite as bad when his
father-in-law was seeking to do it for
redevelopment purposes and we'll get
into more of bata O'Rourke's sterling
political career you know the sort of
thing that really has launched a
thousand ships the sort of thing where
the media just can't help themselves
we'll get some more of that in just a
second first let's talk let's talk about
the holster that you have for your gun
we the people holsters they offer
custom-made holsters all produced in the
United States they design every holster
in-house it means they don't use any
third-party molds for their holsters
instead they design every unique mold in
Las Vegas in order to best fit each and
every firearm perfectly I have one of
these I have a Smith & Wesson
9-millimeter and my we the people
holster fits the fits the pistol
perfectly they constantly update designs
they add new designs every single month
that lets them stay up to date on their
newest models that come out we the
people holsters even have their own 3d
design team they measure every micro
millimeter of their gun to preserve to
ensure the perfect fit they've a unique
intuitive clip design it allows for you
to easily adjust both the cans and the
ride of your holster so that it fits
comfortably and securely at all times
you're able to place the holster on your
back and set that angle and how high or
low it sits on your waist and that
allows for easy access also every
holster has adjustable retention which
is signaled with a click sound which
lets you know your firearm is securely
in place you don't have to worry about
your firearm falling out have custom
printed designs in-house the thin blue
line thin red line the Constitution
camouflage and American flag new designs
every month we the people holster start
at just 37 bucks apiece
every holster comes with a lifetime
guarantee every holster ships for free
and if it's not a perfect fit you send
it back for a refund so you got nothing
to lose right now my listeners can go to
We the People holsters comm slash gun
that is
We the People holsters comm / Ben and
enter promo code Ben at checkout to get
$10 off their first holster that's as
low as 37 bucks and shipping is free
with an additional $10 off using my
promo code again that is We the People
holsters comm / Ben use promo code Ben
at checkout for $10 off go check them
out right now great American company
alrighty so back to the story of beta
O'Rourke so beta O'Rourke was apparently
faulted for his for his associations
with his father-in-law and the use of
eminent domain for for purposes of
supposedly driving up real estate prices
in areas owned by his father-in-law the
New York Times reported on this back in
October they headed a special City
Council meeting in 2006 a billionaire
real estate investor unveiled his vision
for redeveloping downtown El Paso to
replace tenements and boarded up
buildings he proposed restaurants shops
and an arts walk rivaling San Antonio's
Riverwalk representative beta O'Rourke
one of hundreds attending wasn't exactly
a disinterested party not only had he
married the investors daughter but as a
member of the City Council he
represented the targeted area including
a historic Mexican American neighborhood
calling downtown one piece of El Paso
that was missing on the road back to
greatness
O'Rourke voted to take the first step
forward with the plan over the next two
years old work would defend the plan
before angry barrio residents and vote
to advance it at other times he would
abstain business owners who opposed the
plan accused O'Rourke of a conflict
setting the involvement of his
father-in-law 12 years later
O'Rourke is championing progressive
causes but his involvement in that
proposed El Paso redevelopment
highlights a side of his record that
seems to contradict the populist image
he has cultivated in Texas and
nationally
according to David Dorado Romo a local
historian mr. O'Rourke was basically the
pretty face of this very ugly plan
against our most vulnerable neighborhood
barrio residents feared they would lose
their homes through eminent domain and
among a lot of the residents the hurt
feelings have lingered he says that in
the past he never voted for eminent
domain says O'Rourke and no property was
ever taken by the city through eminent
domain and that he had no financial
interest in the project nonetheless his
father-in-law was deeply involved in
this projects there's a lot of suspicion
surrounding that but that's not the only
issue with bado O'Rourke according to
the Houston Chronicle O'Rourke's sunny
vision of immigrants energy in many ways
echoes
father-in-law's focus on cross-border
business developments in a region known
for its young bilingual bicultural
workforce Sanders who is his
father-in-law said the us-mexico border
region is very attractive place to be so
Sanders forms up a bunch of real estate
firms he sold a lot of them for inane I
mean just crazy amounts of money he sold
security capital for 5.4 billion dollars
he was considered one of the founders of
real estate investment trusts REITs and
Sanders and his business associates have
boosted O'Rourke's political career with
generous donations a Roark stepped back
from his family business activities
since 2013 that was when he came under
scrutiny for purchase of stock in
several companies just going public
including Twitter IPOs are generally
reserved for heavy hitters looking for
big profits
O'Rourke said the purchases were made by
a financial professional who manages his
investments they were reported on his
financial disclosure forms when
reporters discovered them he reported
himself to the Ethics Committee which
directed him to send the profits to the
US Treasury by mail overnight he said
that none of the purchases were made on
our behalf because of my position and he
says he has no involvement in his and
his wife's personal investments so great
okay the fact again is that throughout
his career he's been involved with
businesses that are deeply
family-oriented and in which people in
his family stand to make a lot of money
based on his public connections I mean
that for example O'Rourke went back to
El Paso in 1998 he founded Stanton
Street technology group I mentioned that
his mom Melissa O'Rourke eventually
became a shareholder in the company
Amy O'Rourke joined the company as well
and she ran it from the time he went to
Congress in 2013 until March 2017 she
sold all shares in the company for
between 250 thousand and five hundred
thousand dollars according to house
financial disclosure reports one of
Stanton Street's clients O'Rourke since
2011 his political campaigns for the
House and Senate have paid the company
more than a hundred and twenty five
thousand dollars for web hosting and
other online services according to
federal campaign reports so in other
words Boehner O'Rourke raised a bunch of
money for his congressional campaigns
and then paid a company that his wife
was running and she would eventually
sell her shares in the company for
something like half a million dollars
that's beta O'Rourke but don't worry
baito is a man of the people he's a man
of the people who really understand
because he travels around you see he
travels around like a like a Johnny
Appleseed of politics
speaking Spanish talking to the folks
wandering into bars talking with the
people that he's a down-to-earth fellow
who could simply afford to blow several
years of his life wandering around after
after racking up debt at Columbia
University wandering around with a punk
rock band and then suddenly move into a
historic 1915 three-story home once
occupied by Pancho via pretty amazing an
inspiring uplifting story of American
mobility now pretty impressive stuff now
listen as you know I don't tend to
believe that politicians have to come
from nothing in order to be something I
think that you're supposed to judge a
politician on their own merits but
that's not what the media believe the
media tell you that you have to have a
an inspiring personal narrative and so
they have worked very very hard to craft
an inspiring personal narrative for bado
the problem is his actual circumstances
are not in any way inspiring he grew up
privileged he spent his teenage years
privileged he spends his young adulthood
privileged and now he is spending his
adulthood privileged that is not an
inspiring story in any way he made a
bunch of silly decisions including two
arrests and he's basically gotten away
with all of that and he's moved on with
his life and now they're they're
objecting over themselves why because
for a lot of people who work in the
media if you're gonna manufacture a
story about bado it has to be an
internal story you wanna know why all
the media coverage focuses on Beto's
soul on his deep brooding soul it's
because they can't talk about his story
because his story is not only a nothing
burger it's a negative for him in these
primaries there are still some
candidates who have more inspiring
stories in the Democratic primaries
Howard Schultz has a much more inspiring
story than any of those people
nonetheless what you are seeing from
from folks in the media is this worship
of a beta now okay so how is beta
actually going to do in these primaries
how's all this actually going to play
out
we'll get to that in just one second
first let us talk about the food that
you need for emergency preparedness look
the government recommends that you have
food on hand in case of an emergency
there could be some sort of natural
disaster there could be some sort of
power outage and you need food on hand
you can't get to the grocery store the
grocery store is all locked up or all
the shelves are empty well this is why
you ought to work
with wise company they take an
innovative approach in providing
dependable simple affordable
freeze-dried food for emergency
preparedness and outdoor use it is super
easy to use wise wise company and folks
at the company here have tasted it they
say it tastes pretty good when
government resources are strained it can
be days if not weeks before you gets a
fresh food and water you have to rely on
yourself you don't know what tomorrow
can bring but you have peace of mind
knowing you're gonna be ready with
everything you need
not only does wise emergency food taste
really good its quality is unmatched
they don't just slap their name on
someone else's product all of their
ingredients are chef prepared internally
by wise company by doing this they cut
out the middleman and they pass the
savings on to you give yourself the
peace of mind knowing that you're
prepared with plenty of emergency food
well the shelf life of up to 25 years
you just buy it and then you don't have
to worry about it anymore
wise company uses the finest ingredients
and food preparation technology to
ensure optimal freshness and flavor
every recipe is created by a team of
chefs and is unique to wise company wise
company combines both dehydrated and
freeze-dried ingredients to get the best
taste texture and nutritional value
the final recipes are packed into
durable long lasting pouches designed to
moisture and air seeping air seepage
keeping food fresh delicious and ready
to be eaten
even if stored for up to 25 years this
week my listeners can get any wise
emergency or outdoor food product at an
extra 25% off the lowest market price at
wise food storage comm / Shapiro that is
wide wise food storage comm / apparel
shipping is free as well plus wises the
90 day no questions asked return policy
there's no risk in doing this that's
wise food storage comm / capiro to get
any wise emergency or outdoor food
products at an extra 25% off plus free
shipping wise food storage comm / pro
make sure your family protected this is
just a responsible thing to do okay
we're gonna talk about how the poles are
shaping up where does bado show up in
these poles we'll get to that in just a
second first you're gonna have to go
over to daily wire and subscribe $9.99 a
month got to subscription $99 a year
gets the you the annual subscription
which comes along with this the very
greatest and beverage vessels cast your
eyes upon it in envy you could have one
of these you could be holding one of
these right now if you had ordered
already so order right now also the most
sorts of goodies for you when you become
a subscriber so not only can you ask me
questions whenever we do our
conversations you also get to check out
two additional hours a day the
we do of this show ask questions during
the breaks I mean it is a bonanza of
Shapiro material it's almost time for
our next episode of the conversation by
the way Wednesday March 20th 7 p.m.
Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific we're changing
things up we're doing a live book
signing of my new book the right side of
history for this episode only you get to
ask me questions if you have purchased a
copy of my book
so go purchase a copy of the right side
of history and then you can actually ask
me a question during our live book
signing more details to come as we get
closer stay tuned once again you can
participate in my live book signing on
Wednesday March 20th 7 p.m. Eastern 4
p.m. Pacific on this special episode of
the conversation my book launches next
Tuesday I'm really pumped up about it it
should be really exciting I think it's
an important book go check that out
right now also make sure that you get
the subscription obviously to daily wire
and make sure that you subscribe over
YouTube in iTunes that gives you access
to our Sundays specials if you're a
subscriber you get our Sunday specials
on Saturday this week Sunday special
features the inimitable dr. Phil who
shows up for the full hour as Larry King
would say so go check that out right now
leave us a review YouTube and iTunes it
always helps
we're the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
all right so how are the polls showing
up right now well bado is running
currently 4th according to the morning
consult polls Joe Biden is running first
at 31%
I think his lead is the most tenuous
mainly because Joe Biden is not a clever
politician he tends to make a lot of
gaffes it makes a lot of mistakes and so
the moderate lane is kind of open and
you're gonna see bado move into that
moderate lane Bernie Sanders is running
second to 27% I think that if you have
to forecast this this primary process
right now Bernie has to be the
front-runner I've been saying this for
weeks
why because in a 19 candidate primary
the person with the most solid base of
support is going to win that was the
story of Donald Trump in 2016 everybody
else was moving up and down in the polls
Rubio is sometimes doing really well
sometimes Cruz was doing well and then
Trump was just riding there at 30% just
consistently right there at 30% and
everybody else was splitting the other
70% of the vote and Trump was just
sitting there like yeah if I do what you
had they were all attacking each other
assuming he would fade everybody's doing
the same with Bernie it seems they're
all sort of ignoring Bernie
they're attacking each other I would
have if I were a betting man which I no
longer am after 2016 I would be betting
my money on Bernie Sanders in the
Democratic primaries Biden is at 31%
according to morning consult Bernie is
at 27% then there's a massive drop-off
Kamala Harris is at 10% now she already
got her initial boost right her initial
boost came when she announced and she
went from 0% to 10%
she's been stagnant - ever since she's
not really growing and one of the
reasons she's not really growing is
because she does not have the same sort
of appeal particularly in in the black
community that Barack Obama has she was
hoping that you'd get that sort of boost
and should be up around 15 to 20 percent
right now she is not beta O'Rourke was
running at 7% without having declared
Elizabeth Warren at 7% and then the
also-rans cory booker amy claw bashar
pete but a gig which I guess is
pronounced boot as Hesh is that how it's
pronounced I really I think that's how
it's actually pronounced in any case
beta will work at 7% so the real
question is how does bait o run when it
comes to this race well I think it gets
a little boost I think he's probably in
third place which demonstrates once
again the Democratic Party the party of
intersectionality it really make it
easier for white guys don't they and
that means the
three candidates in the Democratic Party
are all white guys so that's exciting
one of the things that is that is
fascinating though is that this morning
console poll shows where everybody's
second preference goes where everybody's
second preference goes and it's pretty
fascinating so look at for example
Biden's supporters so Biden supporters
split like this their second choices so
if Biden starts to go down in flames and
people are shifting their votes where
they're going to go 30% of them say they
will go to Bernie Sanders 30% say they
will go to Bernie Sanders 12% say Kamala
Harris 10% say Elizabeth Warren so that
means there are a lot of Biden
supporters who are actually pretty warm
toward Bernie now the thought I think in
Beto's camp is that Biden supporters
will move on over to bait oh that may be
true he may be younger more moderate he
may have some suburban female appeal but
there's a heavy percentage of Biden's
vote if he goes down that will move over
to Sanders and may move over to Sanders
more quickly if Biden begins to move
toward the moderates Center where do
Bernie Sanders his supporters go
fascinatingly enough most bernisa a
plurality of Bernie Sanders supporters
their second choice is Joe Biden 31% say
they go to Biden 15% to Elizabeth Warren
9% to Kamala Harris Kamala Harris his
supporters are pretty evenly split Joe
Biden 19% Bernie Sanders 18% Elizabeth
Warren 15% for their second choice
Elizabeth Warren supporters would go to
Bernie Sanders so that means that
Sanders continues to have a tremendous
upside in a lot of these polls and beta
O'Rourke's supporters are split evenly
between Sanders and Biden there that
their second choice would be Bernie
Sanders or Joe Biden pretty evenly split
so here's the question what's the lane
for what's the lane for beta Aurora
really we know what Bernie's Lane is
Bernie's Lane is the uber progressive
socialist wing of the Democratic Party
which has some millennial appeal he's
not gonna do great with the black
community he's not gonna do fantastic
with the Hispanic meal - okay with the
Hispanic community he did last time
actually but he's not gonna do amazing
with the Hispanic community he's not in
the moderate lane but he's not actively
alienating the moderates either as much
as he did last time around so what you
are seeing is that Bernie is crowding
everybody else out of his Lane Bernie's
crowding out everybody and the way you
can tell he's crowding out everybody is
a Liz
with Lauren who wanted to rival Bernie
in that progressive Lane is already
shifting to the right she's not talking
about capitalism in a warm and friendly
light which is pretty fascinating since
she wanted Bernie Sanders his vote so
here is Elizabeth Warren yesterday
talking about how capitalism was
actually a force for good believe
capitalism over the course of history
has been a force for good so yes I do
I think it also when when it doesn't
work it's been a force for bad but
that's been true of every form of
government that we can identify that
we've gotten it right sometimes and
gotten it wrong sometimes when you let
markets work with rules and with people
on the beat to enforce those rules we
can produce a lot of wealth in this
country that's what we've done for a
very long time
so Elizabeth Warren sending more like
Howard Schultz there than like Bernie
Sanders so she is trying to run to the
right she feels that Joe Biden is more
vulnerable if she can move over to the
right then maybe she can move into that
Joe Biden category and steal some of his
support the part of the base that is
seen as most vulnerable is not the
progressive socialist part of the base
that part is seen as Bernie's base and
all Bernie has to do is wait for
everybody else to divvy up the rest
that's all he really has to do so I'm
not sure where bado thinks that the
opportunity really lies other than in
overwhelming media coverage of how
wonderful bethe O'Rourke is but again
bitter works background is not
intersectionally inspiring he's not
gonna win a lot of the black vote or the
Hispanic vote he's banking on suburban
women but suburban women may not be
enough of a percentage of the Democratic
primary vote to get him through in my
view bado is running for VP
what bado really wants to that VP slot
now that would be the smart move by the
way if Bernie Sanders were to win the
primaries he'd be smart to pick somebody
like beta O'Rourke even though bado is a
complete lightweight he would be smart
to pick beta O'Rourke because he needs
suburban women and those are the women
who are those are the people who are
most likely to feel unsafe because of
Bernie's socialist policies he might
pick Kamala Harris too just because the
media would push him to pick somebody
who wasn't white but bado is obviously
running for VP if Kamala Harris were to
win the nomination there's very little
doubt that she would pick
betta Oh work for her VP if Joe Biden
were to win the nomination people are
already speculating Biden bado I think
that's unlikely I think more likely is
Biden Kamala Harris in any case the the
fact that beta that beta O'Rourke has
even taken seriously as a national
candidate after losing a Senate race to
Ted Cruz is pretty well insane
there is no shot that bata wins Texas in
a presidential race I don't want a no
shot there's a very slim shot that he
wins Texas in a presidential race in a
presidential race everybody shows up and
Beto's flaws are on full display he lost
to Ted Cruz who is not the world's most
popular politician okay but I guess if
Democrats can deceive themselves into
believing the baito is the wave of the
future then maybe he'll draw just enough
support to to push him into that sort of
presidential territory I don't think so
I don't think so I think the initial
push that you're seeing I don't think
it's gonna last I don't think baito has
quite the magic that Barack Obama did
and the attempt to manufacture magic
typically does not work he feels a lot
more like John Edwards circa 2008 than
he feels like Barack Obama circa 2008
okay meanwhile the attack on Tucker
Carlson continues a pace Media Matters
continues to press against Tucker
Carlson tries to get him Elstad from the
air and this is obviously a concerted
campaign at this point by the entire
left to take away the advertising base
for Fox News because the left just
doesn't like Fox News this has nothing
to do with the specific opinions voiced
by Tucker Carlson on the Bubba the Love
Sponge Show in 2007 it has nothing to do
with that
it is obviously that they're a bunch of
motivated leftist who do not like Fox
News and they will use any club at at
their disposal to beat Fox News about
the ears with it that's why if you
actually look at the footage of Media
Matters his protest at Fox News
nothing was about how terrible Tucker
Carlson's comments was all of it was
about how Fox News should be been
advertised errs do
the Americans support actual real news
because what you're supporting now is
hurting people and is dangerous much
bigger than Tucker Carlson the problem
is this entire network so obviously this
has nothing to do a Tucker right
everything here has to do with they just
don't like Fox News and they have
pre-printed signs by Media Matters to do
all of this well the irony of this of
course is that Media Matters is hanging
its hat on these old comments bye-bye
Fox News's Tucker Carlson back when he
was working for MSNBC but it turns out
that the head of Media Matters himself
has made a bunch of terrible comments
about various minority groups now his
excuse today Angela Karis own who's the
head of Media Matters his excuse is that
when he wrote that stuff he was a parody
he was parroting the right-wing oh so
that's how he's gonna get off the hook
for this uh-huh here's Tucker Carlson
shellacking him last night on a show
Karis own runs Media Matters almost
every day he issues outraged press
releases accusing other people of
bigotry and yet because everything his
irony Kara stone is himself an
enthusiastic bigot we know this for sure
because he has written about it
extensively it turns out that for years
Karis own maintained a racist blog Media
Matters probably ought to issue a press
release about this they've done a lot
more for a lot less but they're not
going to issue a press release about
that huffington post last night ran with
a massive headline about how everybody
should boycott Fox News how everybody
should stop advertising with Fox News
this sort of wave this sort of tsunami
that has come for Tucker Carlson once
again has nothing to do with Tucker
Carlson this is fake outrage everybody
knows that it's fake outrage does that
mean that stuff that Tucker said was
good no doesn't mean the Tucker should
apologize you should apologize to people
he actually harmed you should apologize
to people who were actually victimized
by his comments he shouldn't apologize
to Media Matters for any reason
whatsoever but this is all in bad faith
as we've always known it is in bad faith
in the media covering it as though this
is an actual story as opposed to a bad
faith hit attempt on a fellow
the media is pretty astonishing
honest-to-goodness it is really
astonishing meanwhile president Trump is
is fighting a power battle with the
Senate the Senate was on the cusp of
passing a rebuke to President Trump on
his national emergency declaration as of
last night according to the Washington
Post the Senate prepared Wednesday to
rebuke President Trump over his national
emergency declaration at the us-mexico
border Senator Mike Lee who he had on a
radio show yesterday was leading
compromised efforts he wanted to pass a
bill that would basically allow Congress
to end any sort of funding for national
emergency declarations after 30 days
Trump threatened to veto it and then
that bill sort of fell apart and now
it's turned into a simple showdown where
the Senate is voting to not basically to
condemn or override Trump's national
emergency declaration and Trump is just
gonna veto it
so this will end up in the courts here's
President Trump talking about it
yesterday I think it's a bad vote if
they go against I think anybody going
against border security drug traffic in
human trafficking that's a bad vote the
Democrats are for open borders they're
for crime I mean frankly that's a crime
but I told Republican senators vote any
way you want well vote how you feel good
but I think it's bad for a Republican
senator I also think it's bad for a
Democrat senator to vote against border
security and to vote against the wall I
think if they vote that way it's a very
bad thing for them the long into the
future okay so this is it's a foolish
non strategic move by President Trump to
threaten to veto Lee's bill why because
if Lee's bill had passed it would have
let Congress override the it would have
let Congress override a national
emergency declaration when they don't
agree with the president but what it
would have allowed them to quietly allow
a national emergency declaration to move
forward if they did agree with the
president effectively it acted like the
War Powers Resolution Congress has 30
days basically to withdraw funding from
any sort of war in which the president
is currently engaged it is very rarely
invoked by Congress instead Congress
usually just looks the other way and
lets the executive continue spending
money on foreign conflicts in fact
actually today was the first time in a
long time
that the Senate fought back against the
executives use of War Powers when it
came to Saudi Arabia for example the
Senate voted to cut funding for Saudi
Arabia in Yemen which is kind of fast
and has some ramifications for Middle
Eastern politics considering that Iran
is the other party in Yemen fighting for
control over there suffice it to say
that President Trump is not being
strategic in his approach to this thing
but I'm not sure that strategy really
came into play anywhere here really I
don't think strategy came in into play
at any point along the line will the
wall be built under these conditions
probably not probably it now goes to
probably it now goes to a court which
says this is not a national emergency
Congress just doesn't agree agree with
the president the president doesn't get
to declare a national emergency simply
to overrule Congress in doing what they
are doing so you know the president had
a way out here he didn't take the way
out and frankly you can see from his
administration that everybody in his own
is his own administration is puzzled by
it vice president Pence was negotiating
with the Senate came to an agreement
with Senator Lee and then Trump blew it
all up it's a problem when the greatest
negotiating president of all time turns
out not to be able to negotiate a simple
deal with his own members in Congress
okay time for some things I like and
then some things that I hate so things
that I like today there is great irony
to Elizabeth Warren just wonderful irony
to Elizabeth Warren so Elizabeth Warren
you will recall
wrote on official papers that she was
Native American and the speculation has
long been that Elizabeth Warren used her
quote unquote Native American status to
move forward in the academic world she
was asked on MSNBC about this college
scandal we talked about yesterday in
which parents were paying exorbitant
amounts of money to basically cheat
their kids way into top university here
was Elizabeth Warren talking about it as
a parent how much sympathy would you
have for these parents who are embroiled
in this alleged cheating scandal zero
zero okay okay so she has no sympathy
whatsoever
the irony meter here is off the charts
so in other words if you falsified your
SAT scores to get in the university she
has no sympathy for you but if you
falsified Native American heritage to be
listed in minority faculty listings then
she has tremendous sympathy for you I
mean after all hi she kept Owens run in
her family solid stuff there from
Elizabeth Warren got to enjoy that okay
other things that I like today so
there's an article today called how real
America became queer America by Samantha
Ellen she's an author and reporter come
LGBT issues is a big column in the New
York Times what's hilarious about this
column is that it implicitly
acknowledges that people across the
country who disagree with her on
politics still treat people well she
refuses to acknowledge this in the piece
but like she immediately assumes that
everybody who treats gay people well or
transgendered people well must
inevitably agree with her on the
political issues but the article subtly
understands and accepts that there are a
lot of people in the middle of the
country who disagree with her on the
issues who still treat people really
well who are lesbian gay bisexual and
transgender her article says this may
seem like a strange time to feel
optimistic about the future of LGBT
rights in America but as a queer
transgender woman who has spent most of
her adult life in red states hopeful is
exactly how I feel in July 2017 the same
month that President Trump announced on
Twitter he would ban transgender troops
I left on a six-week long road trip
across the red states I wanted to
understand what motivated LGBT people to
stay in the heartland at a time when
some progressives were still pondering
escaping to Canada what I learned on the
way from Utah to Georgia only reaffirmed
what I have come to believe over the
past decade attitudes toward LGBT people
are changing rapidly in conservative
states and no one inside the beltway can
stop it this country's bright queer
future is already here hiding we're too
few of us care to travel from bird's eye
perspective this person writes it may
not seem that life has changed for LGBT
Americans in so-called flyover country
state laws prohibiting discrimination
against them remain elusive in red
states but in their absence midsize
cities have become pockets of LGBT
acceptance this progress includes
transgender people on my road trip
through what is ostensibly Trump country
I met many LGBT people who saw no need
to flee their conservative home states
for the coastal safe havens of
generations past thanks to local
progress it's so much better said one of
these people it's so much freer it needs
to be reported ok the the inherent
connection between the political
preferences of the left intolerance is
assumed by people on the left but it is
simply not true I've I spent my life
working with religious people religious
Christians religious Jews I spend my
life talking to people in the middle of
the country I spend a lot of time
traveling in the middle of the country
these are nice people being a nice
person can be you can be a nice person
and still disagree with the political
priorities of people
and still treat those people well and
for example I'm good friends with dave
rubin dave rubin is a gay same-sex
married man Dave knows that I believe
that homosexual activity is sinful
because I'm a religious Jew
I've sat with him and his husband I
don't believe in same-sex marriage on
illegal or on a moral level it doesn't
matter I still treat Dave really well
and he treats me really well because we
don't have to agree on political
priorities to understand that each of us
is made in the image of God and that it
is our job to treat people with
Tolerance even if we don't necessarily
like their behavior because guess what
it's not my business it's not my
business on a spiritual level I can
disapprove of something but that's God's
business it is not my job to force
anybody to do anything that is the
perspective I think of the vast majority
of Americans across the political
spectrum of folks on the Left believe
that in order to be tolerant toward LGBT
Americans you must therefore agree with
everything that the LGBT movement has to
say that if you're tight in order to be
tolerant towards transgender people for
example you have to accept that a trans
woman is a woman I do not accept that
but I treat every transgender person
I've ever met I've treated decently
because that's what decent people do
folks on the Left don't seem to
understand that there is a difference
between politics and how you treat
people that decency doesn't necessarily
mean that we agree with you it's why for
the left at conflation between decency
and we agree with you it's why they
believe that if you disagree with them
you are indecent they conflate the two I
know there are a lot of people who
disagree with me on politics or a decent
kind loving people I know that's true
and we just disagree on our political
priorities in many cases that doesn't
mean we can't treat each other with
dignity but for a lot of folks on the
Left if I disagree with them on their
political priority it's because I have a
lack of compassion a lack of care and
therefore I must be the kind of person
who would treat people individually in a
mean way that's nonsense the article
makes that assumption but the article is
wrong but the article is right about is
that LGTB LGBT people across the country
are being treated extraordinarily well
and they are treated extraordinarily
well even in deeply read areas and that
shouldn't be shocking to anybody okay
time for a couple of things that I hate
pretty shocking story in the week all
about Johnny Depp and his ex-wife
Amber Heard so you'll recall that for
years the story was basically the Johnny
Depp had physically abused
Amber Heard his ex-wife and this was
repeated to Amber Heard was used as the
meets Who poster girl
well now it's turning out that it may
have been the other way around
according to the week Depp's Depp has
now filed a lawsuit against Amber Heard
for fifty million dollars for defamation
Depp's lawsuit referred to Hertz
allegation as a hoax he has presented
new evidence who's actually Depp who was
physically abused in the marriage and
not the other way around
and his hurt also knew that her
elaborate hoax works at the lawsuit as a
result of her false allegations against
mr. Depp misheard became a darling of
the me2 movement was the first actress
named a human rights champion at the UN
Human Rights office was appointed
ambassador on women's rights at the ACLU
and was hired by L'Oreal Paris as its
global spokesperson the lawsuit stated
Depp's legal team have provided fresh
evidence alleging heard punched Depp in
the face and chopped a part of his
finger the new video and photographic
evidence submitted showed Epps faced
with a huge bruise and one of his
fingers severed Depp also submitted 87
surveillance camera videos to the court
and 17 depositions of witnesses
including police officers fans have been
apologizing to the actor for accusing
him of abuse it's pretty horrendous
stuff obviously but it just demonstrates
that once again believe all women is
just as nonsensical as believe all blank
you shouldn't believe all anything you
should check the facts and you should
follow the evidence believe all women is
just an excuse for people not doing
their homework or for enshrining their
confirmation bias in the public
consciousness that's all that's
happening there
so and we'll wait to see the rest of the
facts come out reporting 87 surveillance
videos and my goodness if it turns out
the entire media fell for this thing
it's once again demonstration of where
the media sympathies actually lie on
these issues and it's not with the truth
they other things that I hate today
there's an article in The New York Times
all about China's declining birthrate
the title a flurry of ideas to reverse
China's declining birth birth rate but
will Beijing listen now there's
something hilarious about the New York
Times complaining about China's
declining birth
right the real reason that they they're
worried about the declining birthrate in
China of course is because they have a
massive social welfare state
infrastructure it's a communist country
if you don't have young people nobody's
paying the bills and they used a
one-child policy to completely destroy
the future of their country the same New
York Times will call next week for
people not to have kids because of
global warming maybe the New York Times
should do a little soul-searching if it
turns out that no kids in China is a bad
thing maybe no kids in America is also a
bad thing maybe if you want your giant
social welfare state you're actually
gonna have to have an influx of new
people who can work maybe you're gonna
have to have young people maybe if you
want to try and social welfare state
you're gonna have to do what China does
and limit immigration pretty
tremendously it's hilarious that the
same folks will push for a Nordic style
social system refused to acknowledge
that a giant social welfare state relies
on new populations of young people to
work and also relies on restrictive
immigration policies both of which the
New York Times opposes already we'll be
back here a little bit later today with
two more hours of coverage I'm sure
there will be lots of breaking baito
news like he's probably playing a song
right now and brooding and then brooding
and then playing a song and then
thinking and then brooding and being
dark and then brooding so I'm sure we'll
have every brooding update about beta
rook if you want to check that out and
go subscribe over at Daley wire.com if
not we'll see you here tomorrow I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19